l'épidémie de sida a explosé depuis plus
de 10 ans il y a eu en France plus de
25000 malades et il y aurait aujourd'hui
plus de 100000 sérro positif pourtant
beaucoup de Français restent sourds
aveugles ou simplement imprudents sans
doute croi-il que le sidan arrive qu'aux
autres que le virus ne contamine que les
marginaux les toxicomanes les
homosexuels c'est pour combattre cette
dangereuse illusion que malgré leurs
souffran nos invités de ce soir ont eu
le courage de venir témoigner devant les
caméras
Luc vous avez 28 ans vous avez découvert
que vous étiez séropositif en février 91
comment vous l'avez appris ben je l'ai
appris par les dirais-je par le père
de la personne avec qui j'étais en à ce
moment-l il a téléphoné en ce temp je
travaillais en en province il a
téléphoné pour m'avertir que d'après des
résultats sanguins sa fille avait donc
une une maladie qui aurait pu ê soit le
le sida comme il m'a dit ou bien un
cancer quelconque alors moi je me suis
donc inquiété forcément évidemment et
j'ai fait un test de dépistage pour
savoir de quoi il en était à mon niveau
et une semaine plus tard j'ai appris que
ce test était ben positif quoi mais
quelle est la première chose qui qui à
laquelle on pense quand on apprend
ça lorsque je suis sorti de là céit un
matin de février il faisait beau et
j'avais l'impression que tout
s'écroulait quand même comme si euh oui
tout s'écroulait cette impression là qui
est qui est resté la plus forte dans ma
mémoire
surtout vous vous êtes immédiatement
retrouvé j'imagine avec Isabelle pour
pour en parler ah oui absolument le soir
même c'était mon le coup de téléphone
tout de suite pour pour essayer de d'en
discuter mais c'est pas évident c'était
pas facile c'était même très pénible
donc vous vous êtes vous avez été obligé
de de remonter dans votre passé l'un et
l'autre voilà et comment vous vous avez
acquis la conviction que c'était que
c'était vous donc qui aviez contaminé
Isabelle et ben parce que déjà par nos
antécédents
euh de vie en commun voilà il était donc
assezisé de savoir quels étaient nos
autres partenaires nos précédents
partenaires Isabelle ayant eu moins de
partenaire que moi donc ça a été très
vite fait le tour moi enen ayant eu
guerre plus ça pas été trop difficile de
trouver qui mais comment est-ce que
cette personne qui n'était qui était
comme moi ni d'un milieu à risque et
d'une bonne famille quand même a pu se
retrouver seropositive comme ça et à
force et en cherchant et surtout en
retrouvant cette personne j'ai pu
apprendre qu'effectivement
c'était un garçon avec qui il était
sorti peu de temps auparavant avant moi
qui
lui Ben était toxicomane voilà et
lorsque lui il la su plutôt que de lui
dire et bien sûr de le savoir pour moi
il s'est tiré une balle dans la tête
c'estàd il s'est suicidé quoi net et
c'est resté donc elle n'a jamais su
voilà c'est resté un mystère elle l'a su
en fait peu de temps un peu de temps
avant de par de décéder elle-même et
elle lui en voulait beaucoup quoi
voilà comment ça s'est su enfin comment
je l'ai su comment Isabelle et moi
l'avons su toute cette chaîne donc s'est
mise une certaine manière en place parce
que personne n'a dit personne n'a rien
dit de tout Manis mécins il s'est avéré
que une année plus tôt j'avais été
hospitalisé et j'avais une prise de sang
qui s'était révélée positive et elle
m'avait pas été communiquée et donc
c'est dans cette année où j'aurais pu le
savoir que j'ai rencontré cette personne
qui à son tour était contaminé donc par
ma faute vouz dire que un an auparavant
donc vous avez été hospitalisé cela on
vous a fait un dépistage à mon insu oui
à votre insu oui c'estd j'en ai jamais
eu la
réponse je me suis retrouvé à sortir de
l'hôpital je leur dit si j'ai dit ça une
infirmière du service si il y a quelque
chose est-ce que je Seris au courant et
on m'avait dit oui effectivement bon ben
3 mois plus tard toujours pas de
nouvelle j'étais persuadé donc tout
allait bien on a joint l'hôpital hein
vous avez où ce test a été fait pour
savoir ce qui s'était passé et dans
l'immédiat n'a pas vraiment de réponse
en tout cas l'hôpital dit qu'ils ne
savent pas pourquoi une erreur pareille
voilà a pu a pu arriver c'est la seule
réponse qu'on est aujourd'hui ouais
effectivement oui peut-être que la
lettre a été faite qu'elle est jamais
arrivé ou je sais
pas enfin maintenant c'est trop tard de
toute manière vous suspectiez-vous
quelque chose quand il y a eu donc ce ce
test un an aaravant à l'hôpital
absolument pas rien rien rien ne faisait
en en sorte à ce que je puisse suspecter
quoi que ce soit puisque
je j'étais donc célibataire et peu de
temps auparavant j'avais vécu 2 années
et demi avec la même personne donc je
voyais pas la raison pour laquelle quoi
que ce soit pouvait m'arriver
franchement pas j'étais pas dans les
groupes à risquees enfin tel que je
l'avais perçu par ce qu'on entendait à
ce moment-là à savoir toxicomanie
sexualité voà j'étais pas du tout je je
côtois pas ces milieux donc je me
sentais pas du tout enfin je les autres
quoi surtout les autres le fait
d'apprendre hein Luc d'avoir la
conviction donc c'était vous qui aviez
contaminé donc votre ami après avoir
vous-même été contaminé vous êtes
c'était quoi votre sentiments
culpabilité imaginez enfin je pense que
c'est pas très difficile si vous aimez
une personne vous vous voulez pas faire
de mal à une personne et lorsque ça se
produit et ben c'est l'impression de de
détruire la vie de quelqu'un et
quelqu'un qu'on aime et ça c'est
résultat je je me suis retrouvé
à à me mépriser moi-même forcément avec
Isabelle est-ce que ça avec votre amie
ça a détérioré vos vos relations euh au
prabord oui très très très vite la
situation s'est détériorée on a fini par
par ne plus vraiment se côtoyer et puis
le temps passant
ben à force de de me faire murir la
réflexion ben disons maintenant on
s'entend on s'entend bien de nouveau
quoi si ça a fait exploser votre couple
c'est parce que vous étiez vous sentiez
donc vous coupable elle vous
responsabilisz c'est c'est qu'est-ce qui
a fait que ça ça a sauté à ce
moment-là est-ce que c'était trop dur à
vivre entre vous ça était une situation
en fait très très complexe parce que ce
lorsque je l'ai su j'ai perdu mon
travail j'ai perdu mon logement je me
suis donc j'ai quitté la province pour
revenir sur Paris
elle de son côté au niveau de de ces
études ça
devenait plus plus difficile au niveau
de la concentration tout ça et bah on
s'est quitté petit à petit doucement moi
je cherchais un endroit où me
réinstaller et c'était de plus en plus
pénible le fait d'avoir toujours cette
idée en tête qu'est-ce que je vais faire
combien de temps oui on y pense combien
de temps est-ce que je vais durer
qu'est-ce que je vais pouvoir faire dans
l'avenir qu' l'avenir
déjà au moment où vous l'avez appris
vous étiez animateur vous dans oui
j'étais animateur dans un centre dans un
centre d'animation oui avec plusieurs
collèguesit dans la même maison mais il
s'est passé que lorsqu'on est loin de sa
famille et loin des siens j'en ai parlé
autour de moi et ben très vite j'ai
perdu ma place tout a été fait pour je
pour je m quoi enfin que je sois dehors
de la maison plutôt que
dedans en vous disant quoi oh ben en
disant et en faisant quoi
euh faire sa vaisselle tout seul par
exemple ça c'est quelque chose d'un seul
coup personne voulait plus mettons on
manger dans la même pièce dans la même
cuisine on faisait la vaisselle chacun
son tour une vie collective et puis ce
qui s'est avéré c'est que d'un seul coup
je me suis retrouvé exclu de cette vie
de cette cette vie collective à faire
moi-même ma vaisselle déjà je pense à
parce que ça a été la première chose ça
commençait par ça puis ensuite j'avais
un chat alors plus personne voulait
toucher mon chat parce que si mon chat
m'avait griffé des tas de petites choses
comme ça des pas
vraiment pas vraiment dur à supporter
directement mais tous les jours à
constater c'est vrai que c'est c'est
angoissant
Luc donc ces personnes qui travaillaient
avec vous au centre c'était des gens qui
étaient quand même un peu au courant
non de la transmission quand
même parce dans ce que vous dites
apparemment les gens ne savent rien
apparemment il s'imagine qu'on peut
attrapp même encore aujourd'hui je
rencontre beaucoup de gens qui qui n'ont
aucune idée de de la facilité de
transmission de de cette maladie vous
vous êtes retrouvé à leur expliquer
justement que ça se faisait pas comme ça
en se touchant et que c'était ah oui
ouioui bien s d'ailleurs nen parle je
n'en parle jamais par exemple je ne dis
jamais que je suis s posositif pourquoi
parce que tout de suite je me suis rendu
compte que les gens ont un regard
différent de à partir du moment où on
lit on vous apprécie très bien quand
vous dites rien et à partir du moment où
vous le dit ben soit les gens sont
vraiment trop complaisants et ça devient
insupportable ou soit ils sont il ne
portent plus d'attention à vous quoi
c'est oui mais mais vous l'exclusion
hein dans laquelle vous vous êtes trouvé
oui ça a été comme ça tout tout au long
de de ces quelques années ça a commencé
par le Centre et ça a été
avec vos amis avec d'autres personnes
bah c'estàd après cette expérience très
difficile qui pendant 6 mois m'a laissé
à côté de la plaque j'avoue
bien cette cette exclusion ben je je
l'ai effacé à partir du moment où jeai
plus dit quoiùù j'ai vécu comme tout le
monde sans sans jamais sans jamais rien
dévoiler je n'en parle pas mais dans le
milieu ouvrier c'est c encore une chose
qui n'existe
pas le sida c'est encore encore encore
une bonne plaisanterie je l'avoue he par
exemple dans mon cas on va à la visite
médicale on sort donc de la visite il y
a les collègues qui attendent dehors et
la première chose qu'ils font c'est de
rigoler alors on t'a dit que tu avais le
sida bon bien sûr le mieux c'est dire
oui oui c'est me suis retrouvé dans
plein de situations rocambolaises dans
ce
style des amis voilà des amis que je
connais depuis des années amis d'enfance
qui me disent mais tu imagines en
parlerit du sida mais mais tu imagines
si tu avais le C là et je suis obligé de
dire non j'imagine pas vous votre
famille le sait non non non ma famille
ne le sait pas ça un groupe très
restreint de une dizaine de personnes
doent le savoir attendez pourquoi vous
ne l'avez pas dit à votre famille euh je
n'ai pas pu le dire
pour j'ai tenté de le dire disons quand
même au départ j'ai voulu essayer de le
dire mais comment je ne savais pas et un
jour de but en blan j'en ai parlé à mon
père qui
euh n'a pas pas du tout voulu croire la
blague la l'énorme plaisanterie que
j'étais en train de lui faire quoi
c'était pas possible c'est et en fait
mon père a eu la réaction que je mentais
je disais ça pour me rendre
intéressant j'en ai pas parlé à ma
mère pour ne pas lui faire de mal et
j'avais peur d'une réaction similaire
et et ça a amené à à ce que finalement
il ne le sache pas quoi aujourd'hui et
pourquoi d'après vous votre père n'a pas
pu
l'entendre est-ce que c'est une mauvaise
information parce que
est-ce parce
que c'était trop dur à acceptter je sais
pas je sais pas j'en ai jamais reparlé
avec lui par la suite puisque ça avait
plutôt mal tourné la conversation j'ai
préféré ne jamais la remettre sur la
table donc là le le fait de de le he de
venir le dire ici c'est aussi pour qu'il
pour qu'il l'apprenne donc pour pour
qu'il en soit convaincu surtout parce
que je seraai pas là sinon je pense h
c'est cela et Isabelle son entourage le
sait oui son entourage est plus au
courant que le mien ou
et je dirais qu'elle a été quand même
beaucoup plus soutenue au départ que
moi-même puisque je n'en avais parlé
qu'à un groupe restreint qui lui m'avait
exclu alors que elle c'était adressé à
sa famille qui bien sûr pas exclu est-ce
que l'un et l'autre vous avez
reconstruit une vie affective à côté
est-ce que vous avez une petite copine
un petit
copain personnellement pour mon cas non
et quant à Isabelle elle a elle a tenté
et je crois qu'elle a réussi à
effectivement à à reconstruire une une
vie amoureuse enfin différente certes
mais quand même
moi non je préenant voilà en prévenant
que moi j'en suis encore au stade de la
culpabilité je n'arrive
pas
à revivre comme avant je n'y arrive pas
c'est un blocage mais par exemple pour
avoir des relations sexuelles il suffit
de de mettre un préservatif pour avoir
une vie sexuel normal certes
certes mais en arrivé là maintenant
c'est comme un cauchemar quoi c'est
c'est une peur c'est une peur tout
simple c'est une
[Musique]
peur j'entends j'entends ça de la
manière où à partir du moment où où
relation sexuelle il y a il y a il y a
un côté amour il y a un côté réciprocité
et si je suis sincère je ne peux pas
c'est une question de sincérité quoi je
ne peux pas aimer quelqu'un tout en
sachant que il suffirait
d'unun d'un rien pour pour briser la vie
de quelqu'un nouveau ça je ne veux pas
c'est je ne supporterait pas quoi et
est-ce que c'est aussi la peur de de
dire aussi la peur de d'avoir à dire à
une personne avec qui on pourrait avoir
envie de construire quelque chose ou qui
pourrait avoir envie de construire
quelque chose avec moi-même le fait de
dès le
départ mal partir parce que finalement
j'arrive pas à imaginer ça comme avant
comme avant avant que je le sache comme
avant que je sois malade enfin malade
c'est positive
plutôt c'està-dire
c'est c'est une nouvelle vie quoi une
vie
différente vous êtes repris sur malade
vous considérez comme vous ne vous
considérez pas comme malade ou je ne me
considère pas comme malade oui je me
considère en pleine forme d'ailleurs
parmi tous mes collègues je crois que
j'ai bien la
frite depuis maintenant un an j'ai j'ai
pu depuis la ZT depuis ma prise de ZT
j'ai plus aucun problème de santé
transformé votre vie oui oui je suis
reparti sur j'ai DIRIS sur une
nouvelle nouvelle route enfin j'espère
et je souhaite que qu'elle dure et c'est
pour ça que
je c'est pour ça que je considère pas
malade quoi encore des projets j'ai
encore envie de faire plein de choses
j'ai j'ai encore beaucoup de souhait
j'ai beaucoup de choses en tête beaucoup
de encore plein de choses quoi à faire
donc je me considère pas malade si je me
considère malade je serai malade c'est
évident le fait de savoir hein que vous
êtes séropositif est-ce que ça
transformé votre vie je parle pas des
des exclusion du travail et tout mais
vous dans votre tête est-ce que vous
avez du coup vécu différemment oui oui
oui oui maintenant il est vrai que je je
vis différemment mais pour beaucoup de
choses lorsque je fais quelque chose de
de pénible et de rebutant je me dis que
j'ai déjà la chance d'être là pour le
faire avant je n'y prêtais pas attention
avant
je bah je vivais au jour le jour enfin
peut-être moins mais sans sans y faire
attention surtout tous les jours je
vivais sans diffire
attention là maintenant j'ai vraiment
l'impression d'avoir les P de d'amocles
auudessus de la tête et que chacun
instant qui passe est un instant
savourer un instant à prendre
pleinement savourer l'instant présent
quoi que vous disiez tout à l'heure que
c'était c'était difficile hein parfois
le le regard des des gens l'attitude des
gens autour de vous et là le fait de
venir témoigner donc ça ça un véritable
acte de courage mais est-ce que vous
n'avez pas peur non plus que demain ça
change des gens si bien sûr si bien sûr
mais mais je dirais je suis peut-être
arrivé aussi à un moment où je me sens
prêt à
affronter je crois que l'émission
s'appelle B les masques je crois que je
suis prêt à retirer le masque maintenant
je moi j'aimeris ne plus avoir honte
d'être malade quoi c'est ça la pire des
choses parce
que je connais des gens qui ont eu des
maladies terribles qui s'en sont sorti
tant mieux pour eux mais lorsqu'il
disait qu'il avaiit un cancer tout le
monde est
était conciliant quoi allez dire que
vous avez le sida et tout de suite c'est
c'est l'opposé qui se
produit donc c'est
c'est c'est embêtant c'est même
attristant quoi c'est un petit mot là ce
que vous dites ou h c'est un ehémisme
ou vous justement qu'est-ce qui vous a
amené vous à témoigner Luc sachant que
toute démarche
justement de vérité par rapport par
rapport à la séropositivité au sida peut
amener une démarche d'exclusion encore
plus grande qu'est-ce qui vous a amené
justement àer ce
témoignage
peut-être s s'il y a une chose que je
pouvais peut-être faire pour Isabelle
et
c'est éventuellement pour d'autres
Isabelle qui pourrai rencontrer d'autres
Luc
quoi avenir si ça peut être ma manière
de de mettre la puiss à l'oreille à des
gens qui l'ont pas encore ben je me
sentirai déjà mieux au niveau de ma
culpabilité l'impression que c'est
beaucoup plus à elle que vous pensez en
permanence qu'à vous et que vous
témoignez aussi beaucoup pour
elle aussi oui si si seulement je
pouvais faire quelque chose pour la pour
que si on pouvait revenir en arrière si
je pouvais pour moi bon c'est c'est
c'est un fait mais c'est dommage quoi
parce que bon l'hôpital mais euh aurait
pu me prévenir ça aurait été un établi
quoi j'aurais été sopositif mais je
l'aurais pas transmis c'est surtout ça
qui est important j'aurais pas transmis
c'est ça surtout
que qui étéit difficile à à
digérer il est toujours difficile à
digérer
d'ailleurs parce qu'on on n' pas
l'impression que vous aviez justement du
vous de la rancune vis-à-vis de de votre
autre compagne qui non même pas oui je
l'imis aussi quoi c'est toujours le même
problème quoi tout ça en fait c'est pour
mon cas le sida c'est une histoire
d'amour finalement c'était il y a 6 mois
lorsque vous avez entendu le témoignage
de votre fils Luc à la télévision
comment vous l'avez pris est-ce que ça
n'a pas été trop violent de l' prendre
de cette
façon-là si ça a été un choc quand même
parce que de l'apprendre de cette façon
mais enfin ça moi ça m'a permis de de
connaître un autre Luc bon ben j'ai
découvert que depuis de nombreux mois il
avait vécu tout seul vraiment et avec ça
sur Ceid ce poids avec ce poids là quoi
donc ça a dû êtres très lourd pour lui
lu avait avait était venu avoir un
caractère exécrable on ne pouvait plus
rien lui dire qu' il prenait la por tout
de suite il nous envoyait promener alors
que c'était pas du tout son style et
vous ne compreniez pas pourquoi non et à
partir du moment où Luc a su qu'on le
savait on a pu en discuter ensemble
pourquoi d'après vous vous ne pouviez
pas entendre votre fils quand il a
essayé de vous le vous le
dire nous avions des rapports assez
tendus ne voyant pas
travailler je me suis dit que c'était
des des blages qui me raconai et puis
c'est tout jeis resté
là dans mon cocon bon ben quand j'ai vu
votre émission je l'ai visionné quatre
fois et j'ai là j'ai compris euh mon
erreur et et j'ai
vu j'ai
compris la détresse où était mon
fils pourquoi d'après vous vous n'avez
jamais pu en parler entre vous ben c'est
dire c'est très difficile d'annoncer à
ses parents qu'on risque de partir avant
eux c'est quelque chose qui est très
enfin même inimaginable je pense pour
pour des parents alors leur annoncer euh
quelque chose d'une maladie dont il ne
connaissent pas tout et d'ailleurs ce ne
sont pas les
sals c'était forcément leur donner un
choc que j'avais pas envie de de leur
offrir comme ça gravement quoi et
peut-être que la télévision a atténué
cet effet de de de de direct alors que
ça semble amplifié au contraire ça
par qu'ils ont pu ils ont pu m'entendre
sans avoir à me couper est-ce que vous
vous sentez vous libéré de l'avoir
dit c'était vraiment cette sensation de
de déposer le le
fardeau de de toutes mes idées qui
pouvaient être Sasser intérieurement
quoi qui qui par exemple je pense que
durant cette période j'ai réussi à
douter que que mes parents étaient extra
quoi quand même pour tout dire il a
réintégré le cercle familial
voilà nous avions une certaine distance
mon fils et puis moi et nous nous sommes
tous
rapprochés vous n'avez pas peur du
regard des autres de vos amis du tout
pas du tout ah pas du tout non bon si si
les autres nous nous regardent mal parce
qu'ils nous aurons vu pass à la
télévision témoigné pour le sida et
bien disons pour eux hein c'est qu' ne
comprennent pas et puis c'est tout euh
c'est le moindre
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne in
mire Duma abonnez-vous et activez la
[Musique]
cloche